[Music]
I've always just like this it's just I'm
bringing it back now like I remember
doing some events back in the day like
we just I just I've always been you know
kind of out there I guess Aaron Carter
fits the theme
donning all white to the 27th annual
Angel awards gala on Saturday where he
spoke to eat cheese Carly Steele about
his recent preposition on Twitter
it has Chloe Glick grace Moretz
responded to your tweet yet asking
around a date we'd let you guys would be
cute no that's okay and and she doesn't
know me and like she said you know maybe
we'll meet one day you know I think I
was a blip being a little too
flirtatious on Twitter and I think she's
beautiful and actually I actually had a
crush on her before she even knew it I
just thought she was too young for me
which there was a time when she was too
young I'm gonna be 30 this year let's be
real so seriously thirty wow that's
amazing number seven thirty thirty yeah
what about um porcelain black I was your
date with her it was great it was great
yeah you know I but I'm I'm here so low
and I I think I am actually looking
forward to spending time alone and on my
own doing my own thing and and focusing
on on Aaron versus jumping right into
anything crazy you've shared so many of
your stories and inspired so many people
with your social media and what you
share what's been the fan reaction back
to you the fan reaction has been amazing
to be honest with you there hasn't it
hasn't all been good but that's the
reality of our world and what I'm trying
to do is just stop the hate stop the the
judgment the bullying and all those kind
of things that happen all the time and
it's not just with celebrities we just
deal with it on a larger scale and I
think that you know I want to stand up
for the people like my fans a lot of
fans come to me and they say thank you
for your music and it's because my EP
was written about my ex ex-girlfriend
and now the rest of my album is written
about my ex-girlfriend
[Music]
you